the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video alright my
friends in this video we will be looking
at the new official video showcasing hbo
max's lineup for next year we got a good
look at their new lineup of films and
shows that we'll be releasing very soon
in this new video hbo is once again
reminding us that regardless of all the
lockdowns house of the dragon will be
here for its scheduled release date
don't any of you worry house of the
dragon is moving full steam ahead now i
say that because unfortunately there are
still some fans who think this show was
cancelled but that is not accurate the
only show that was officially shut down
was the one about the long night house
of the dragon on the other hand isn't
going anywhere just yet now in this new
video we did see some familiar scenes
from house of the dragon's very first
season as a matter of fact the very
first thing we see is daemon targaryen
walking through what is most likely the
case on dragonstone although there is
always an outside chance that this could
also be the dungeons in the red keep of
king's landing now let's go through all
of the scenes from house of the dragon
because one of them did slightly reveal
something new the very next thing we see
from house of the dragon is king viserys
targaryen sitting on the new iron throne
while holding the valyrian steel sword
black fire after this we see several
members from house valeron as they are
entering one of the main dining halls
during what looks like some sort of
feast or celebration then about halfway
through the video we see a young
rhaenyra targaryen as she is walking up
to the iron throne it does look as if
her father king viserys targaryen is
sitting there waiting for her however i
will admit that it could also be daemon
sitting there while viserys isn't around
as you all know it certainly wouldn't be
the first time we saw someone sitting on
the iron throne that didn't belong there
but your father has to confess
he has to confess and say that i'm the
king
no tyrion should apologize immediately
unacceptable disrespectful
and in very bad taste
i am the king
i will punish you any man who must say i
am the king is no true king
now rhaenyra and daemon is actually who
we see next in this teaser video here we
see a much older rhaenyra standing on
the beach of either dragonstone or
driftmark with her lover slash uncle
daemon targaryen then we see a massive
dragon skull which most fans believe is
balerion the black dreads considering
just how large it is i would say that is
a safe assumption
now immediately after this is when we
get some new footage although it is only
one second longer than before as we get
a glimpse of this scene we can see
alison hightower running with the
valyrian steel dagger in hand she's
obviously very upset about something
making her have this reaction many fans
believe this has something to do with
her and viserys targaryen's son amon
losing his eye this might actually be
shortly after that when alison is
demanding justice for her son's injury
she's basically demanding an eye for an
eye i think this is also a safe
assumption although i cannot confirm
anything until we actually see what
happens in the episode now overall this
new video didn't really show us anything
new it was more or less just a remix of
the same scenes we have already seen
either way it still has me very excited
for the show this reminded me of when
hbo would release videos like this
before and it would always have new
scenes from the upcoming season of game
of thrones videos like this would always
drive the fandom into a frenzy because
we all knew this meant that the new
season was right around the corner
thankfully house of the dragon will be
here very soon the years and years of
waiting is about to finally come to an
end and i for one cannot wait as always
i will be here making videos on every
single scene we see in that first season
of the new series i will be breaking
down each and every episode as well as
making videos about what i think will
happen next for those of you that have
been subscribed to my channel for many
years you know those have always been my
favorite videos to make
make sure you subscribe now so you can
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding game of thrones
house of the dragon and a song of ice
and fire once again i would like to
thank all of you for watching these
videos i would not be making them
without you so with that being said i
hope i will see all of you here for my
next one i also want to say merry
christmas and happy new years for those
of you who do celebrate the holidays
have a great day everyone i will see you
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you and i were meant to be together
forever
but now our time in this world must end
but don't worry paul
i've prepared for what must be done
i put two bullets in my gun
one for you
and one for me
now don't be afraid
[Music]
we must finish the book
i'll fix you something to eat
annie
yes paul
i'm almost done
oh paul
remember how for all those years nobody
knew who misery's real father was
or if they'd ever be reunited
it's all right here
does she finally marry ian or will it be
winthorn
it's all right here
paul you can't
why not
i learn it from you
[Laughter]